welcome to the presentation on the
indefinite integral or the
anti-derivative so let's let's begin
with a bit of a review of the actual
derivative so if i want to take the
derivative
d
dx it's just the derivative operator and
if i want to take the derivative of the
expression
x squared this is an easy one
if you remember the derivative
presentation
well this is pretty straightforward you
just take the exponent that becomes the
new coefficient right you actually
multiply it times the old coefficient
but in this case the old coefficient is
1. so 2 times 1 is 2
and you take the
variable 2x and then the new exponent
will be 1 less than the old exponent so
it'll be 2x to the 1 or just 2x so that
was easy if i had y equals x squared we
now know that the slope at any point on
that curve it would be
2x
so what if we wanted to go the other way
let's say if we wanted to to start with
2x and i want to say 2x
is the derivative
derivative
of what
well we know the answer to this question
right because we just took the
derivative of x squared we figured out
2x but let's say we didn't we didn't
know this already you could probably
figure it out intuitively
how you can kind of do this operation
that we did here how you can do it
backwards right
so in this case
the denotation well we know it's x
squared but the notation for trying to
figure out um 2x is the derivative of
what we could say that
let's say let's say 2x is the derivative
of y
whoops of y
so 2x is the derivative of y
all right let's get rid of this of what
2x is the derivative of y
then we can say this we can say that y
is equal to and i'm going to throw some
very fancy notation at you and i will
explain it more either actually i'll
explain why we use this notation in a
couple of presentations down the road
but you just have to know at this point
what the notation means or what it tells
you to really do it's really just the
anti-derivative or the indefinite
integral so we could say that y is equal
to
the index indefinite integral
of 2x
dx and i'm going to explain what this
squiggly line here is and dx but all you
have to know is when you see when you
see the squiggly line and this dx and
then something in between that you
really all they're asking is they want
you to figure out what the
antiderivative of this of this
expression is
and i'll explain later why this is
called the indefinite integral and
actually this notation will make a lot
more sense
when i show you what a definite integral
is but let's just take it for granted
right now that an indefinite integral
which i just drew here it's kind of like
a little squirrely thing
is just the anti-derivative so
y is equal to
the the the anti-derivative essentially
or the indefinite integral of the
expression 2x
so what is y equal to well y is
obviously is equal to x squared
let me ask you a question is y just
equal to x squared
because we took the derivative and now
clearly the derivative of x squared is
2x but what's the derivative of x
squared
what's the derivative of x squared plus
1.
well the derivative of x squared is
still two x
and what's the derivative of one
right derivative one is zero so it's two
x plus zero or still just two x
similarly what's the derivative
of x squared
plus two
well the derivative of x squared plus
two once again is two x
plus zero
so notice the derivative of x squared
plus any constant is 2x
so really y could be x squared plus any
constant and for that any constant we
put a big c there so x squared plus c
and you'll meet many calculus teachers
that will mark this problem wrong if you
forget to put the plus c when you do an
indefinite integral
so you're saying sal okay
you've shown me some notation you've
reminded me that you know the derivative
of any constant number is zero but this
really doesn't help you solve an
indefinite integral well let's think
about a way that a systematic way if i
didn't do it for you already that we
could
solve an indefinite integral
let me clear this
clear make it black again
let me make a bolder color i think would
make this more interesting
so let's say we wanted to say let's say
we said y
is equal to
the indefinite integral
of
let's say
let me let me throw something
interesting in there let's say is the
indefinite integral of x
cubed
dx
so we want to figure out some function
whose derivative is
x to the third
well how can we figure that out well
it just from your intuition you probably
think well it's probably something times
x to the something right
well let me write it so let's say that y
y is equal to a
x to the n right
so then what is d y d x
d y
d x or the derivative of y
is then well we learned this in the
derivative module you take the exponent
multiply it by the coefficient so it's a
times n
a times n and then it's x
to the n minus 1 right
well in this situation we're saying that
x x to the third is this expression it's
the derivative of y right
this is equal to x to the third
so this is equal to x to the third
what's n
what's a and well yeah what's a and
what's in well n is easy to figure out
right n minus 1 is equal to 3.
so
that means that n is equal to 4.
right and then what is a equal to
well
a times n is equal to 1 right because we
just have a 1 in this coefficient this
is this has a starting coefficient of 1.
so 8 a times n is one if n is four then
a must be one fourth right
so just using this definition of a of a
derivative i think we now figured out
what y is equal to right y is equal to
1 4
x
to the fourth
i think you might start seeing a pattern
here
well how did we get from x to the third
to 1 4 x to the fourth well we increase
the exponent by one and whatever the new
exponent is we we multiply it times one
over that new exponent so let's think if
we can if we can do a generalized rule
here
that
the indefinite integral oh oh and of
course
plus c i would have failed this exam
so let's make a general rule
that if i have the integral of
well since we already used a let's say b
times x
to the n
dx
right
what is this integral this is an
integral sign
well my rule is is i raise the exponent
on x
right by 1 so it's going to be x to the
n plus 1
and then i multiply x times the inverse
of this number so times
1 over n plus one
and of course i had that b there all all
the time and one day i'll do a more
vigorous uh more rigorous proof and
maybe we'll be vigorous as well as to
why this b just stays multiplying but
actually if you i mean actually i don't
have to do a too rigorous overproof if
you just remember how a derivative is
done you just multiply this times the uh
whatever times the exponent minus one
right so here we multiply the
coefficient times x
one over the exponent plus one right
it's just the inverse operation so let's
just do a couple of examples like this
really fast i have a little time left
i think when the examples at least for
me really hit the point home so let's
say i wanted to figure out the integral
of five
x to the seventh
dx
well
i take the exponent increase it by one
so i get x to the eighth and then i
multiply the coefficient times 1 over
the new exponent so it's 5
8 x to the 8th and if you don't trust me
take the derivative of this take the
derivative
dtx
of
5 8
x to the 8th
well you multiply 8 times 5 over 8 well
that equals 5
x to the and then the new exponent will
be 8 minus 1 5x to the seventh
and it applies to oh and of course plus
c i
don't want to forget the plus c
so i think you have a sense of how this
works in the next presentation i'm going
to do a bunch more examples and i'll
also show you how to kind of reverse the
chain rule and then we'll learn
integration by parts which is
essentially just reversing the product
rule see in the next presentation